all of that understandable to everybody
was that was the breakdown
nice and clear for you shaq yes the way
you broke it that was very very
understandable
okay so what you think of of how things
shook out
i mean i understand you know even before
i was
was playing and you know you got voted
in and
you know the the way was broken down
today
i still think damon lillard should be a
starter
you know based on what you know uh chuck
and kenny always say who has the better
wreck and all that and
he's actually playing better you know
luca has more assists but
you know nobody is feared in the game
like the daymond lillard got
i'm sure he's not upset about it but
you know time in and time out he's been
he's been
pushed off this list so i i i would have
liked to have seen him as a star i'm not
mad at
how i win and you know how the fans
voted and all that it is what it is but
i would personally i would have liked to
see him start
that's a tough i mean that was a that's
a tough call those three
curry doncic and lillard i mean come on
i i mean what about donovan mitchell
yeah yeah but well donald mitchell's had
a great year too but i
even when i was looking at it i was
saying those are the three the
popularity contest lucas is going to win
uh but like shaq said the most fair man
in basketball right now is damon lillick
i think in terms of getting the ball in
key situations
he was my preseason mvp because i
thought he could do this
put numbers up he was gonna have to do
that all year for his team to be
successful
he's he's still i would say top three in
terms of mvp voting
uh if you if you're that you should be
starting that's all that
there's no doubt about it that he is one
of the top five basketball players
in the world and if you're not starting
and you can't even start in your
conference
if you're one of the top five basketball
players in the world that doesn't make
sense to me as well
well i listen uh there's no right or
wrong answer but i thought dame lillard
and donovan mitchell to me uh
when you have the best record in
basketball that says a lot if you're the
best
uh you know they have these stupid
arguments about who gets mvp every year
the mvp
mvp has never went to the best player it
always went to the player who was the
best player on the best team
michael jordan kobe bryant shaquille
o'neal should have won three or four
but they the other guys played better
that season donovan mitchell should be
rewarded
in my opinion no disrespect to anybody
but this kid has been the best player on
the best team in the nba
and it's unfortunate he's not started